Speaker 2: OK, so it's happening again.
Speaker 1: It happened to Marjorie Taylor
Greene, and it is now potentially going to
happen to Republican Congresswoman Lauren
Boebert.
Speaker 2: We have seen numerous
Speaker 1: videos uncovered in which Lauren
Boebert implies or alludes to Muslim member
of Congress Ilhan Omar being a terrorist wearing
backpack bombs refers to the squad as the
jihad squad and is generally a gross person.
As a result, some Democrats are now moving
to strip Lauren Boebert of all of her committee
assignments.
Is this a good idea?
We're going to talk about it first.
Let's look at examples of what Lauren Boebert
has been saying in a play three of them here
for you.
She has told a very similar story a few times.
Here are a few of those versions of the story.
Speaker 3: Now, I've had a little bit of fun
in Congress.
No, I haven't gone toe to toe with AOC.
She doesn't show up to work.
Sorry.
She votes by proxy.
I did feel Hon Omar the other day and I said,
all cute.
The jihad squad decided to come in for work.
One of my staffers on his first day with me
got
Unidentified: into an elevator.
In the capital and in that car,
Speaker 3: in the elevator, we were joined
by Ilhan Omar.
Well, it was necessary in there, and I looked
over and I said, well, look in there, we had
one.
No, actually, I
have no concern for you.
So.
So the other night on the House floor is not
the my first jihad squad moment.
So I was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers, and he and I are we're leaving
the capital.
We're going back to my office and we get an
elevator and I see a Capitol Police officer
running hurriedly to the elevator.
I see threat all over his face and he's reaching
him at the door, shutting.
I can't get over it.
Look what's happening?
I looked to my left, and there she is.
Go on, Omar.
I said, Well, she doesn't have a backpack.
We should be fine.
Speaker 1: So this is very vile stuff.
Speaker 2: And as a result,
Speaker 1: Massachusetts Democratic Congresswoman
Ayanna Pressley is moving to have Lauren Boebert
removed from every single committee on which
she sits.
Pressley announced her resolution yesterday
morning.
Let's take a look at that clip.
Speaker 5: We have heard the hate and credible
threats that have been directed at Rep. Omar
and her staff.
Words have consequences.
We must acknowledge that and respond with
action.
We've introduced this resolution today to
do just that and to send a powerful message
to every Muslim and every marginalized person
who has ever questioned their place in this
country or in the halls of power.
We see you.
You belong.
You are powerful and you deserve a life free
from fear and filled with dignity and love.
How we respond in moments like these will
have a lasting impact.
And history will remember us for it.
Speaker 1: Now I have two views on this, and
Speaker 2: I do want to hear from
Speaker 1: you about it on the merits.
If you just say, Does this woman, Lauren Boebert
deserve to
Speaker 2: be on any
Speaker 1: committees?
The answer is, of course not.
Speaker 2: Of course not.
Speaker 1: On the merits.
She shouldn't be on a single committee.
She shouldn't be in Congress.
I wouldn't trust her to mow my lawn or run
antivirus software on my computer.
You know, I don't want to minimize any, any
job, but what I'm saying is even simple jobs.
Speaker 2: She has no business.
I wouldn't want her doing anything.
Speaker 1: Oh, David, sir, are you saying
she shouldn't earn a living?
Guys, let's let's take it easy, OK?
She's incompetent.
Speaker 2: Her presence in the House
Speaker 1: of Representatives as a legislative
body is a disgrace.
But to some degree.
Is it kind of a pyrrhic victory when Democrats
do this to these very much deserving of it
being done to them Republican?
Speaker 2: They did it to
Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Now they're looking very strongly at doing
it to Lauren Boebert.
Well, what do you?
I mean a pyrrhic victory.
A pyrrhic victory is a victory.
Which in so achieving the victory you do damage
to yourself were at the end of the day, you
say I won, but did I really win?
Did I really come out ahead?
And what I mean by that is the following Republicans
are not in the majority
Speaker 2: right now, regardless.
Speaker 1: So Democrats still control the
committees.
You are stripping them whoever it is.
Boebert?
Marjorie Taylor Greene, you're stripping them
of their committee assignments.
You allow them to claim victim status.
You allow them to martyr themselves and they
immediately start raising money on it.
I've been canceled and so on and so forth.
And I want to say it
Speaker 2: again so that people don't misunderstand.
Speaker 1: It's not wrong to remove them.
It's right Boebert has no business being involved
in anything in Washington, D.C..
But what I'm wondering is what is truly accomplished,
for example, Marjorie Taylor Greene within
hours of being stripped of her committee assignments.
She was fundraising.
She was sending out fundraising emails, saying
They've canceled me.
Donate in order to help me do whatever, I
don't even know what the argument was, but
it was, they've canceled me and give me money,
so I'm not arguing that it's the wrong
Speaker 2: move, it's the
Speaker 1: right move on the merits.
But what I'm wondering is whether we end up
helping Republicans more than hurting them
when we do this to them because they go to
I've been canceled.
And I told you that Democrats cancel people
Speaker 2: and now you've got to help me get
on canceled.
Speaker 1: For Boebert, it's almost a dream
scenario.
Less work.
Speaker 2: She gets talked about in
Speaker 1: right wing media.
It gives her something to fundraise on.
So what really needs to happen is she's removed
from Congress.
That's a much tougher and certainly much longer
uphill battle.
Speaker 2: So let me know what you think.
Speaker 1: Net benefit or not,
Speaker 2: when these folks are removed
Speaker 1: from their committee assignments.
Remember also Tuesday, December 14th, 6:00
p.m. Eastern will be the next David Pakman
Show Viewer Town Hall.
It will be the last town hall of the year.
I hope you'll join us.
It'll be streaming live on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel.
That's the second channel.
Very much looking forward to it.
I want to take a second just to thank everybody
who has signed up on our website this week,
I told you at the start of the week, it's
been a tough for a few months as far as membership
goes, and we had this idea.
Speaker 2: Anybody who signs
Speaker 1: up for a full price yearly membership
will send you a free T-shirt if you would
like it.
Speaker 2: And a bunch of people
Speaker 1: have taken advantage of it.
And I can't tell you how much I appreciate
it.
You can sign up at join Packman NJ.com.
Very easy to do.
You can use.
You can.
You can use a coupon code.
You can get a monthly membership, a yearly
membership.
The coupon code is better.
21.
If you would like a free
Speaker 2: T-shirt with your
Speaker 1: membership.
You got to do a year and full price the 60
bucks.
You know we're trying to raise money, not
lose money.
And if you do that, you can email info at
David Pakman dot com after signing up, just
let us know your mailing address and the T-shirt
Speaker 2: style, size
Speaker 1: and color that you would like.
Three important details
Speaker 2: and we
Speaker 1: will get that right out to you.
Free with your full price
Speaker 2: yearly membership or get a discounted
Speaker 1: monthly
Speaker 2: two bucks a month.
Very, very
Speaker 1: good deal, guys.
Join Pacman dot com.
Really appreciate everybody's
Speaker 2: support.